good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight since the day that
donald trump became president democrats
in washington have told you you have a
patriotic duty to hate vladimir putin
it's not a suggestion it's a mandate
anything less than hatred for putin is
treason
many americans have obeyed this
directive they now dutifully hate
vladimir putin maybe you're one of them
hating putin has become the central
purpose of america's foreign policy it's
the main thing that we talk about entire
cable channels are now devoted to it
very soon that hatred of vladimir putin
could bring the united states into a
conflict in eastern europe
before that happens it might be worth
asking yourself since it is getting
pretty serious what is this really about
why do i hate putin so much has putin
ever called me a racist has he
threatened to get me fired for
disagreeing with him has he shipped
every middle class job in my town to
russia did he manufacture a worldwide
pandemic that wrecked my business and
kept me indoors for two years is he
teaching my children to embrace racial
discrimination
is he making fentanyl is he trying to
snuff out christianity does he eat dogs
these are fair questions and the answer
to all of them is no vladimir putin
didn't do any of that so why does
permanent washington hate him so much
if you've been watching the news you
know that putin is having a border
dispute with a nation called ukraine now
the main thing to know about ukraine for
our purposes is that its leaders once
sent millions of dollars to joe biden's
family not surprisingly ukraine is now
one of biden's favorite countries biden
has pledged to defend ukraine's borders
even as he opens our borders to the
world that's how it works invading
america is called equity invading
ukraine is a war crime
so with every day we move closer to some
kind of conflict with russia a conflict
that could easily spin out of control
given that the people running this have
no fine motor skills
the administration assures us this has
nothing at all to do with repaying joe
biden's personal debts to ukrainian
oligarchs not at all it's completely and
totally unrelated the point here is to
defend democracy not the ukraine is a
democracy it is not a democracy
ukraine's president has arrested his
main political opponent he has shut down
newspapers and television stations that
have dared to criticize him so in
american terms you would call ukraine a
tyranny
but joe biden likes ukraine so putin bad
wore good
how will this conflict affect you will
affect you quite a bit actually energy
prices in the united states are about to
go way up and that means that everything
you buy will become much more expensive
from the food you eat to the car you
drive to tickets you need to take your
family on vacation this summer assuming
you can still afford vacation by then
you're about to become measurably poor
that's not a guess joe biden has
admitted this on the other hand you're
going to win an important moral victory
against dastardly old vladimir putin who
is much much worse than justin trudeau
just so you know so you can feel good
about that because
because
let's see come to think of it why would
you feel good about that
it seems like a pretty terrible deal for
you and for the united states hunter
biden gets a million dollars a year from
ukraine but you can no longer afford to
go out to dinner
that's not a bargain
so what are we missing here what we're
missing is the big picture and that's
why joe biden has dispatched kamala
harris to explain that picture to us
kamalaires's old job was to open
america's border she did that her new
job is to keep ukraine's borders closed
kamal harris was in europe the other day
to explain the whole thing she began
with a history lesson letting the
european peoples know about their recent
past which she assumes they've forgotten
since so few of them speak english
she opened with the traditional
salutation listen guys because that's
the way real historians and states
people talk
watch kamala educate
i mean listen guys
we're talking about the potential for
war in europe
i mean let's really take a moment to
understand the significance of what
we're talking about
it's been over 70 years and through
those 70 years as i mentioned yesterday
there has been peace and security
we are talking about the real
possibility of war in europe
listen guys you may be europeans who
live in europe but you don't fully
understand the ramifications of war in
europe that's your problem the thing
about europe you've had peace and
security for more than 70 years kamala
harris just told the europeans that and
that by the way is true if you don't
count the breakup of yugoslavia which
caused hundreds of thousands of deaths
in the 1990s or the soviet occupation of
half of the land mass which managed the
enslavement of hundreds of millions
but apart from that mrs lincoln it's all
been peace and security in europe until
now the soviets were fine vladimir putin
is bad
what do we do about that kamala harris
explained that too watch
and the allied relationship is such that
we have agreed
that the deterrence effect of these
sanctions is still a meaningful one
especially because remember also we
still
sincerely
hope that there is a diplomatic path
out of this moment
and within the context then of the fact
that that window is still opening all
the open although it is absolutely
narrowing
but within the context of a diplomatic
path still being open
the deterrence effect we believe has
merit
got that take a breath and let it sink
in here it is again quote we have agreed
that the deterrence effect of these
sanctions is still a meaningful one
especially because remember also we
still sincerely hope that there is a
diplomatic path out of this moment and
within the context then of the fact that
the window is still opening still open
although it is absolutely narrowing but
within the context of a diplomatic path
still being open the deterrence effect
we believe
has merit
well of course it has merit the only
question is what the hell are you
talking about and the answer is kamal
harris has no real idea what she's
talking about she can't even point to
the direction of what she's talking
about her mouth opens and predigested
chunks of language come tumbling out in
no particular order
it's soothing to listen to until you try
to understand what it means
as kamala harris told us just last month
quote it is time for us to do what we
have been doing and that time is every
day
to which we'd respond that's right ms
vice president person today is the first
day of the rest of your life learn it
love it live it and while you're at it
eat pray love
you could just imagine vladimir putin's
reaction to all this when an aide drops
a translated transcript of kamala
harris's remarks on his desk
the slavic mind is a hall of mirrors it
sees traps at every intersection clearly
kamala harris must be setting some sort
of trap for the russians here
her words don't make sense but she can't
possibly be dim and childish
america is a superpower it would never
put a senile man and an imbecile in
charge of the country
on the other hand maybe so
and by the way it's not just our country
a few weeks ago the russian foreign
minister sergey lavrov met with his
british counterpart liz truss
lavrov asked trust if her country
recognized russian sovereignty over
rostov and veronas both of which are
actually parts of russia
so it was a trick question but liz truss
who used to work in sales had no idea so
she replied that great britain would
never recognize these regions as russian
despite the fact they already are
russian
so liz truss has no idea what she's
talking about either but here's the
thing she wasn't embarrassed about that
none of them are embarrassed about that
john bolton knows a lot on the other
hand he spent decades weakening america
with terrible foreign policy ideas and
getting a lot of decent people killed
for no good reason at all so you'd think
at this point if justice were real john
bolton would be living in isolation and
shame somewhere spending his days in
atonement that's what you would do but
that's not what he's doing no here's
john bolton msnbc demanding yet another
war this one with the nuclear armed
power watch
do you think that u.s forces should
actually go in to defend ukraine well i
think it's probably too late for that
now but i would say this the red line
between being a treaty ally of the
united states and not being one is
significant but the issue as in all
issues like this is would a russian
invasion and takeover of ukraine
adversely affect american national
security and that of its nato allies the
answer that's absolutely yes we did not
act appropriately early i think we
should have had more american forces in
ukraine not to fight the russians but to
train with the ukrainians and to show
those russian generals looking across
the border and seeing american flags i
wonder what that means biden took that
off the table saying there would be no
american forces involved and he got
nothing for it
so the only problem with joe biden's
ukraine policy says john bolton is that
it's too weak your kids aren't fighting
there right now hunkered down in
february shooting at putin
let's try a winter war in russia no
one's done it before but we have high
hopes
alexander vinman is in fact demanding it
unlike the british foreign secretary
alexander vinman knows quite a bit about
ukraine in fact he was born there
alexander vinman believes you have a
moral obligation to defend his homeland
and if you don't you're a murderer watch
him once again on msnbc
i think these folks
these right-wing pundits and the gop
that supports him really frankly have
blood on their hands because
they're encouraging and enticing this
kind of opportunism from uh from putin
and it's not what it's not just kind of
uh
plain rhetoric and like you could say
something without consequences like too
often happens in the
in the united states this has real
consequences and people are gonna die
because of this
yeah they're gonna die
so
your job is to take up arms in defense
of alexander vinman's home country or
else you're evil you have blood on your
hands and that's effectively our policy
okay alexander vinman you got us it's a
compelling argument we're in
what's this going to cost us to defend
the country you were born in well in
fact joe biden addressed that question
today defending freedom will have cost
for us here at home biden said we need
to be honest about it
really bad went on to outline what he
called the pain of our sanctions watch
we're implementing full blocking
sanctions
on two large russian financial
institutions
veb
and their military bank we're
implementing comprehensive sanctions on
russian sovereign debt
that means we've cut off russia's
government from western financing it can
no longer raise money from the west and
cannot trade in its new debt on our
markets or european markets either
starting tomorrow and continuing in the
days ahead will also impose sanctions on
russia's elites and their family members
they share in the corrupt gains of the
kremlin policies and should share in the
pain as well
because of russia's actions we've worked
with germany to ensure nordstream 2
will not as i promised will not move
forward
so let's put aside the question of why
you would ever want to shut down any
energy pipeline anywhere ever especially
now crude oil is near nearing a hundred
dollars a barrel that's the highest
price since 2014.
that's not a small thing because you
need energy to live it's not negotiable
so how does having less energy help the
united states joe biden didn't even hint
at an answer to that he didn't answer
any questions he ran away the second he
had finished reading the script
back in real life every person knows
nothing will tank our economy faster
than cutting off supply of fossil fuels
because despite what you may have heard
from noted energy experts like sandy
cortez a country of 340 million people
can't run on windmills and solar panels
and even if we had enough of those which
we don't we don't have the transmission
lines to get that power to your house
and we won't for a long time so that's
all a lie
but don't worry says kamala harris the
administration has ways of fixing the
spike in energy prices they've got it
under control because it turns out
kamala harris is secretly in charge of
global energy markets
no just kidding harris has no idea what
a barrel of oil costs she doesn't know
how natural gas is measured what she
knows about is diversity and that's
pretty much it though she does sense
that everything is about to get a lot
more expensive for you and so to warn
you she mentioned it today
the president has already said americans
will be facing some economic fallout or
some hardships can you explain to
americans what exactly will they face if
this happened sure as the president
talked about in his speech
um we are aware that again when america
stands for her principles
and all of the things that we hold dear
um
it requires some times for for us to put
ourselves out there
in a way that maybe we will incur some
cost and in this
situation
that may relate to energy costs for
example
so what are the principles we're
defending here were defending a regime
that has arrested
their main rival and shut down
opposition media what principles at
stake here apart from rewarding the
biden family's patron but at least she's
honest enough to say what's happening in
eastern europe quote may relate to
energy costs that's a euphemism for good
luck filling your truck this august
does that bother kamal harris maybe it
does in the short term voters aren't
going to like it in november their party
will be punished
but they're doing it anyway they're
shutting down domestic energy pipelines
here they're picking a fight with
europe's biggest gas supplier so maybe
there's something bigger at work here
maybe they're thinking long term maybe
they're not against rising oil and gas
prices may be there for them maybe
expensive energy would be good for the
many renewable deals their friends and
donors are invested in
we don't know the answer we do know that
all of us are about to suffer so we hope
that hating vladimir putin was worth it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else